Sobre el papel tendrían que ser dos grandes
aliados. Algo así como el Batman y Robin
o el Frodo y Sam de la política internacional.
Veréis, me explico.
Japón y Corea del Sur son países relativamente
libres en un entorno geopolítico dónde esta
condición no es habitual.
Comparten socios, se enfrentan a las mismas
amenazas y tienen fuertes lazos económicos.
¿Os parece poco?
(Japón y Corea del Sur tienen el mismo aliado
estratégico: Estados Unidos, un país que
tiene desplegados entre los dos países casi
80.000 soldados. Prácticamente un ejército
completo.
Además, los dos países se enfrentan a los
mismos retos estratégicos, fundamentalmente
al envejecimiento, a Corea del Norte y al
creciente peso económico, político y militar
de China.
Pero eso no es todo.
Además, con un comercio bilateral que anualmente
supera los 80.000 millones de dólares y un
tránsito de más de 10 millones de turistas,
las economías de Japón y Corea del Sur están
muy interrelacionadas.)
Ya lo véis.
La teoría nos dice que tendríamos que estar
ante dos buenos amigos.
Y ojo, porque Juntos, Corea del Sur y Japón
forman un bloque mucho más fuerte de lo que
podríais imaginar.
(Hablamos de un bloque con 177 millones de
habitantes;
una economía combinada de más de 6,5 billones
de dólares;
una producción industrial que duplica la
alemana o multiplica por 5 la de Francia
Y con más de 90.000 millones de dólares,
tienen el tercer mayor presupuesto militar
de todo el planeta, tan solo por detrás de
Estados Unidos y China.)
Vamos, que si tuvierais que trabajar como
consultores de estos dos gobiernos seguramente
les recomendarías estrechar lazos y trabajar
codo con codo. ¿Verdad?
Pues, amigos, esperad un momento porque una
cosa es la teoría y otra la realidad.
Lo cierto es que Japón y Corea del Sur se
llevan fatal.
Y eso es lo que explica noticias como esta:
(Incidente naval ocasiona un aumento de tensión
entre Corea del Sur y Japón. Zona Militar)
(Olvídese de Corea del Norte: Japón Vs Corea
del Sur, ¿El próximo enfrentamiento en Asia?)
Y, ¿sabes qué? Ahora más que nunca el tema está que arde.
¿Queréis una prueba? Atentos.
(Según un estudio realizado en julio de 2019
ni más ni menos que el 74% de los japoneses
desconfían de los surcoreanos.
Por el otro lado las cosas no son mejores.
El 75% de los surcoreanos no se fía de los
japoneses)
Pero ahí no queda todo.
A principios de julio de 2019 el gobierno
de Japón desató una especie de guerra comercial
contra Corea del Sur.
En concreto restringió las exportaciones
de 3 productos clave para la industria surcoreana:
La Poliamida fluorada, el fluoruro de hidrógeno
y los fotoprotectores.
Puede que no hayas escuchado nunca nada sobre
ellos pero hablamos de 3 productos químicos
imprescindibles para fabricar semiconductores
y las pantallas de los smartphones.
Dos componentes en los que Corea del Sur es
uno de los mayores fabricantes y exportadores
del mundo.
[De hecho, podríamos decir que los semiconductores
son algo así como el petróleo surcoreano]
("Corea del Sur es el líder mundial en la
fabricación de chips, y Japón es el líder
mundial en la fabricación de los materiales
clave para producir chips", Ahn Ki-hyun, vicepresidente
de la Asociación de la Industria de Semiconductores
de Corea. )
Y ahí no termina todo. A comienzos del mes
de agosto Japón anunció nuevas restricciones…
que pueden no ser las últimas.
Pero, amigos, antes de continuar, creo que
debemos hacernos algunas preguntas…
¿Qué diantres está pasando? ¿Por qué
Japón desata semejante conflicto con uno
de sus mayores socios comerciales? ¿Qué
consecuencias puede tener?
Atentos.
(LA RECONCILIACIÓN QUE NUNCA LLEGA)
Para comprender toda esta historia tenemos
que remontarnos hasta principios del siglo XX.
Desde el año 1910 hasta el final de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial en 1945, Corea fue una colonia
de Japón.
No fueron años precisamente felices para
los coreanos.
El Imperio de Japón dirigió Corea con mano
de hierro; la represión fue muy dura; se
cometieron una enorme cantidad de crímenes
y muchas tierras fueron de facto expropiadas.
[Para que os hagáis una idea, mientras el
pueblo surcoreano pasaba hambre gran parte
de la producción agrícola era enviada a
Japón.]
Y eso no es todo.
(Además, durante la ocupación japonesa cientos
de miles de surcoreanos fueron reclutados
a la fuerza para trabajar en condiciones brutales
de semiesclavitud en la industria y en las
minas japonesas.
La Universidad de Stanford estima que fueron
más de 700.000 surcoreanos.)
Y si pensáis que esto es terrible, esperad
un momento porque aún podemos encontrar cosas
peores.
Durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial decenas
y decenas de miles de mujeres surcoreanas
fueron obligadas a ejercer el oficio más
antiguo del mundo para “satisfacer” a
los soldados japoneses.
Se calcula que fueron entre 50.000 y 200.000
las mujeres víctimas de esta atrocidad.
Amigos todo esto es lo que explica que 7,
7 décadas después, Japón y Corea del Sur
continúen peleandose por lo que significó
la ocupación.
(Un gobierno regional cercano de Seúl está
pidiendo que todos los productos escolares
de fabricación japonesa tengan una etiqueta
que diga que fueron hechos por" criminales
de guerra ". SCPM)
Por supuesto, desde que Corea del Sur recobrará
su independencia en 1945, han sido mucho los
intentos para reconciliarse y pasar página.
Los dos más importantes se produjeron en
1965 y en 2015. Ambos con el mismo resultado.
(En 1965, cuando Corea del Sur era una dictadura
dirigida por Park Chung-hee los dos países
llegaron a un acuerdo para poner punto y final
a las disputas.
Japón asumió su responsabilidad y se comprometió
a pagar al gobierno surcoreano el equivalente
a 2.400 millones de dólares actuales como
compensación y otros 1.600 millones en préstamos
con bajos intereses.)
Sin embargo, en el año 2012 la Corte Suprema
de Corea del Sur reconoció el derecho de
las víctimas a obtener una compensación
individual.
Ojo no del gobierno japonés sino de las empresas
japonesas que estuvieron involucradas en los
casos de trabajo forzoso.
(El fallo de la Corte Suprema de Corea del
Sur abrió la puerta a que en 2018 las empresas
Nippon Steel, Mitsubishi Heavy Industries
y la Nachi-Fujikoshi Corporation fueran condenadas
a pagar entre 70.000 y 90.000 dólares a cada
una de las dos docenas de víctimas que habían
reclamado ante la justicia.)
Ojo, a ellas o a sus parientes vivos. Porque
claro, algunas ya habían fallecido.
¿Os imagináis que ocurriese lo mismo con
el resto de trabajadores forzosos, que sus
familias pudieran reclamar hoy?
Estaríamos hablando de indemnizaciones de
miles, decenas de miles de millones que por
supuesto Japón no tiene ninguna intención
de pagar,
[entre otras cosas porque desde su punto de
vista todo este tema se solventó con el acuerdo
de 1965.]
(Por otro lado, en 2015 los dos gobiernos
acordaron que Japón crearía un fondo de
unos 9 millones de dólares para compensar
a las mujeres que fueron víctimas de la esclavitud
durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial.)
Pues… ¿Sabéis qué? Este acuerdo tampoco
valió para nada. ¿Por qué?
Atentos.
(LA ESTRATEGIA DEL FUEGO MÁS GRANDE)
La economía de Corea del Sur no atraviesa
sus mejores momentos. Es algo de lo que ya
os hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik en
un vídeo que os dejo en la descripción.
Amigos, desde que Moon Jae-In llegó al poder
las cosas se han ido torciendo casi tan rápido
como desaparecen las fotos de snapchat.
Y, por supuesto, detrás de la economía ha
ido la propia popularidad del presidente.
(Según las encuestas la aprobación del presidente
Moon Jae-In cayó desde el 83% que tenía
en mayo de 2018 hasta el 45% un año más
tarde.
Y no solo eso, además en un momento en el
que los asuntos económicos cobran cada vez
más peso la aprobación a la gestión económica
del líder surcoreano se ha desplomado hasta
el 30%.)
Y, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, ¿qué
haces cuando tienes un fuego enorme pero quieres
que la gente mire hacia otro lado?
Pues montar otro fuego aún más grande.
[A ver no lo digo yo, es una de las recetas
más antiguas de la política.]
Pues eso es exactamente lo que parece estar
haciendo Moon Jae-In: echar gasolina al fuego.
[Que por otra parte tampoco es algo que le
haya costado mucho.]
Desde que llegó al poder en 2017 ha tenido
a Japón en el punto de mira.
De hecho una de sus primeras acciones fue
anunciar unilateralmente y con efecto retroactivo
la suspensión del acuerdo del 2015.
(Y suma y sigue.
Durante el último año nos hemos encontrado
con declaraciones políticas cada vez más
polémicas;
la inteligencia surcoreana ha empezado a reducir
la información que comparte con Japón;
En diciembre de 2018 según fuentes niponas
una fragata surcoreana fijó su radar de tiro
sobre un avion japones.
Poco después Seúl impidió el uso de sus
puertos por parte de los barcos de las fuerzas
de defensa de Japón
E Incluso a comienzos de 2019 hemos visto
un boicot a la compra de productos japoneses
instigado por el propio gobierno surcoreano.)
Vamos que si lo que busca es pelea, parece
que el presidente surcoreano no podría estar
haciéndolo mejor.
(Actualmente, la relación bilateral es tan
mala como en los peores momentes y continua
deteriorandose. Ahn Yin-hay, profesora de relaciones
internacionales en la universidad de Corea)
El caso amigos, es que parece que Moon Jae-In
no pensaba que Japón iba a responder con
tanta contundencia.
[¿O tal vez sí?]
(TRUMP ABRE LA PUERTA, JAPÓN LA CRUZA)
Donald Trump abrió la veda: utilizar el comercio
como arma arrojadiza en las negociaciones
políticas internacionales.
(Ahora Japón ha ido un paso más allá: utilizar
la guerra comercial para castigar a un aliado.
Japón está harto.
Y Shinzo Abe está hasta las narices. Considera
que el tema de Corea del Sur y las rencillas
pendientes ha ido demasiado lejos.
El acuerdo de 1965, las disculpas del 90,
del 91, el acuerdo del 2015. Tokyo no está
dispuesto a hacer más concesiones.)
[Claro que, para ser justos, tampoco ayuda
que el mismo Primer Ministro sea un revisionista
convencido. Os hablamos de ello hace muy poquito]
El caso, amigos, es que a comienzos de julio
el gobierno japonés decidió castigar a Corea
con la restricción a los tres componentes
que hemos visto:
La Poliamida fluorada, El fluoruro de hidrógeno
y los fotoprotectores.
(Hablamos de una medida que de no revertirse
pronto podría causar grandes problemas a
gigantes surcoreanos como Samsung o SK Hynix,
dos de los mayores productores de semiconductores
del mundo.
Y eso no es todo.
A principios del mes de agosto el gobierno
de Japón comunicó su decisión de sacar
a Corea del Sur de su lista blanca de 27 países
con estatus comercial preferente, es decir
países que pueden comprar libremente, sin
ninguna restricción, la tecnología y la
mayor parte de productos japoneses.
De esta forma, para comprar prácticamente
cualquier producto, excepto alimentos y madera,
las empresas surcoreanas tendrán que cumplir
un proceso de aprobación por parte del gobierno
japonés, lo que no solo implica más burocracia
y costes de importación sino sobretodo que
ahora el gobierno japonés pasa a tener la
sartén por el mango.
Puede vetar a su antojo cualquier venta a
Corea del Sur.)
Esto amigos es algo que dadas las profundas
relaciones comerciales entre los dos países
puede llegar a suponer un duro, un durísimo
golpe para Corea….
Y, ojo, no solo para Corea, también para
Japón que tiene un superávit comercial con
su vecino de más de 20.000 millones
de dólares.
¿La excusa oficial?
Qué Corea del Sur no garantiza que todas
esas exportaciones de productos y tecnología
con posible uso militar no lleguen a Corea
del Norte.
Y es que, por ejemplo, productos como el fluoruro
de hidrógeno no solo se utilizan para producir
semiconductores, sino también para el enriquecimiento
de uranio o la fabricación de gas sarín.
Por supuesto, amigos, esto no parece más
que una excusa. El motivo real, es la interminable
controversia entorno al pasado colonial.
(Las acusaciones japonesas son muy serias,
pero no han proporcionado evidencia de ninguna
colusión entre Corea del Sur y Corea del
Norte hasta el momento, "Céline Pajon, experta
en Japón en el Instituto Francés de Relaciones
Internacionales.)
Claro que, llegados a este punto, amigos,
la pregunta que podemos hacernos es ¿tiene
sentido recurrir a la guerra comercial como
arma arrojadiza en política exterior?
Pues lo cierto es que la experiencia nos dice
que no.
Veréis, ahora el gobierno de Corea del Sur no solo ha respondido con sanciones propias
sino que también está poniendo sobre la mesa mucho dinero
para reducir su dependencia de las empresas
japonesas.
(Es algo parecido a lo que ocurrió con China
en 2011.
En aquel momento el gobierno chino restringió
la venta de tierras raras a Japón.
¿Y qué hicieron los japoneses? Pues invertir
en sus propias minas. Al final la cuota de
mercado de China se redujo [al tiempo que
a los contribuyentes japoneses les tocó pagar
el pato.])
Es decir, un resultado malo para todos.
Así que es posible que en esta ocasión a
Shinzo Abe también le salga el tiro por la
culata.
En fin, amigos, lo que se espera es que Japón
y Corea tarde o temprano regresen al punto
de partida y, de esa forma, continúen esta
interminable espiral de agravios.
(De momento Japón ya ha concedido un permiso
para la venta de fotorresistentes a Samsung.
Eso sí, a partir de ahora, el proceso será
más lento y el gobierno japonés tendrá
siempre en su mano decidir si aprueba o no
la venta, de forma totalmente arbitraria.
Por eso, sí, es probable que las cosas vuelvan
en cierto modo a su cauce, sin embargo de
aquí en adelante habrá muchos matices y
muchas tensiones)
Pero, ¿sabéis qué? Sería bueno para todos
que de una vez por todas zanjaran este asunto.
[Han pasado 70 año. Ya vale, ¿no?]
(EL BLOQUE)
Amigos, una estrecha alianza entre Corea del
Sur y Japón sería algo muy bueno. Formarían
un bloque económico y político con mucha,
muchísima influencia.
Ahí está por ejemplo el acuerdo de libre
comercio con China, que Japón y Corea del
Sur están negociando conjuntamente [Bueno,
ahora con Moon Jae-In se ha frenado] para
crear un espacio de comercio aún más grande
y profundo.
Eso sería bueno para todos.
A nivel político serían algo así como un
faro en una zona del mundo repleta de dictaduras.
Y a nivel militar, serían capaces de ser
todo un contrapeso a China. Incluso más allá
del ejercito que Estados Unidos tiene desplegados
en estos países.
Pero por supuesto, para lograr todo esto es
esencial, necesario, imprescindible, que los
dos gobiernos lleguen a un acuerdo que de
una vez por todas les permita dejar atrás
al pasado y centrarse en el futuro.
Amigos, estoy seguro de que ahora entendéis mucho mejor que está ocurriendo entre Corea y Japón.
Espero que este vídeo os haya resultado interesante,
si ha sido así no olvidéis darle a like
y suscribiros a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.